i'm just trying to be the best no no
dude you don't miss a misunderstanding
my friend right my whole thing is like
you know i want to do the best i can
right and i'll get what i get right i
just wonder why other people get the
thing something i can't get can i just
say that
fly on the wall yeah go ahead i'm very
into this new bobby lee it is it is i i
don't know
what knew bobby lee what are you talking
about
can you tell us like compare two
differences
uh i mean look we [ __ ] around and we
found out bobby got self-esteem and this
is what happened i i hadn't i hadn't
listened to the podcast i literally know
bobby is someone that is like you know
we are very open about our insecurities
and low self i turned in the pockets and
i was just like skipping around and it's
like i'm bobby lee [ __ ] like you
said it a couple times i'm bobby lee i'm
bobby lee i'm like that is what i'm
talking about yeah yeah i i feel like
you therapized have broken through
something i don't maybe in the last year
maybe it was the pandemic maybe it was
what happened with all that drama but
you're in a
i just feel that you are have arrived to
another level of
understanding of your worth and i think
it's awesome i would i would have to
agree well because you react to things
that aren't real yeah i mean or maybe
you did that show at the [ __ ] ace and
we're like if if you if you call
yourself not fight you're calling your
fans dumb
you know i mean you know it's it's it's
it's like this it's like you know i
you can't i can't walk around right
going i'm a piece of [ __ ] i can't get
nothing and all that whole [ __ ] thing
right and then i'm like you know doing a
scene with sarah just like a parker in
new york and then she's like wanting to
know who i am and all that stuff and in
my head it's like my inner voice isn't
matching what the reality is right so
it's like i'm just trying to match my
reality with you know
with my voice like to say that you're
not successful that's like if that's
like on some q and on [ __ ] it's like
it's yeah yeah it's delusional it's
delusional it's insane and everyone is
just like okay so wait you that and
you're right
because
yeah i used to do that even you know
this is the thing that bothered
uh you about me was that like after i
would do well on stage i would go i
bombed right and it was just the same
way of trying to like you know but it
didn't that didn't even make any sense
when you would bring it up like that i'm
you because one day you
pulled me and said stop i can't do this
anymore well it was before you were
hiring and but i just
before i think sometimes when you have a
maladaptive behavior that works really
well for you either like you're
minimizing yourself making yourself
small to walking on eggshells around
narcissists or you know borderlines like
that maybe worked really well to shrink
yourself or be like i'm a piece of [ __ ]
i'm ugly that that i did that same [ __ ]
it worked for me because it made the
narcissists in my life not feel
threatened by me and it made me feel
safe so
when i would see before you went on
stage like i'm i'm gonna bomb i'm gonna
bomb on the bomb you know and i'm like
maybe this was like something a tool he
developed so that other comedians
wouldn't be threatened by him and this
is how he survived in the hallways and
then and you would go like i'm going to
bomb a bomb and you'd be like nervous
before going on most of people are there
to see you and then you go on and
destroy in a way that means
okay but i know i know you're being i
don't
know
10 years in
every night for 10 years it i i was like
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah and then i was
like
you know sometimes you just need
permission sometimes for someone to say
like oh you don't need to do that right
and something clicks and i was just for
like a year i was like what if i just
said no don't say anything it's not your
business how dare who are you he's so
much he's senior to you like and then
one day i just
said it yeah
yeah
i'd like to make a comment that might be
inappropriate go ahead um
since we are no longer in a relationship
okay tell your leg
[Laughter]
the worst um thing about breaking up
though is being at the comedy store
because there are people
that i never talk to
that are going like i'll see them and
they'll be like bring it in oh god you
hate that and i go what they're all just
so psyched kyle was single
but it's like even
people i've barely talked to
come on buddy
right and i'm like and i have and i want
to be a dick so i'm kind of like okay
and i'll just kind of give them a hug
and they're like man
if you need ever need anything they're
doing the [ __ ] i don't know you have
any of you gotten dms from people trying
like i've um i finally got my first one
oh really what did it say why are you
you don't have to be
just i got excited it was my one and
only i've never got one
yeah go ahead go ahead i want another
yeah
and i don't want to get into it but it
was like you know one body
one body part yeah yeah and you know me
she said uh i want to [ __ ] you it was it
was kawhila
it was a [ __ ] burner and